economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches daniela ya sabemos que las
economías en américa latina tienen
muchos problemas pero la pandemia hizo
que nos retrocediéramos casi 10 años de
avance si santiago muy buenas noches
miren la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos y
otros tres organismos coinciden en que
la pandemia hará que el pib regional
retroceda a niveles de 2009 esto
significa que la región volverá a una
cifra de pobreza de más de 200 millones
de personas o sea 4 de cada 10
habitantes de ese total casi 100
millones pasaría a vivir en la pobreza
extrema a finales de este año todo esto
por cuenta de los 27 millones de
empresas cerradas que deja la pandemia
hasta el momento y así arrastra millones
de empleos el informe publicado hoy
mantiene la previsión de que américa
latina tendrá una contracción económica
del 9 por ciento este año que es más que
la del resto del mundo santiago hablemos
ahora el reino unido- porque ya están
diseñando planes para poder hacer frente
a esta segunda ola de contagio de kobe
19 y evitar
espíritus bueno en este nuevo programa
consta de tres aspectos en primer lugar
se extenderá por seis meses el pago con
recursos públicos de hasta el 80 por
ciento del salario de quienes hayan
visto afectados por la pandemia por el
lado de los impuestos las actividades
turísticas también seguirán disfrutando
de un recorte temporal del iva y las
empresas también reciben su parte
escuchemos
para darle mayor flexibilidad para
reembolsar sus préstamos vivos estamos
introduciendo un esquema de pague a
medida que crece esto significa que los
préstamos pueden extenderse de 6 a 10
años casi reduciendo a la mitad el pago
mensual promedio el 5 de abril
mons ley repeat mente esto en el reino
unido- daniela pero en eeuu también
revivió un debate en torno a posibles
nuevos paquetes de estímulos para la
economía santiago será un llamado que
venía haciendo la reserva federal para
que se apruebe un nuevo paquete de
estímulos por 22 billones de dólares el
primero fue por 2 billones el debate
lleva siete semanas estancado y esta
semana se iniciaron nuevos esfuerzos
legislativos para llegar a un difícil
consenso entre republicanos y demócratas
los primeros recordemos son los más
reacios a la idea que los segundos de
que haya un nuevo paquete mientras tanto
el número de solicitudes de apoyo por
desempleo subió inesperadamente a 870
mil la semana pasada no es una cifra tan
grande santiago como llegó a hacerlo a
comienzos de la pandemia
a mediados de marzo 68 millones de
personas estaban pidiendo este auxilio
porque perdieron sus empleos pero la
cifra si es más alta que en la época de
la gran recesión de la década del 30
cuando esas peticiones llegaban a los
700.000 hablemos de bruselas de la unión
europea puntualmente que están
proponiendo allí la primera regulación
de cripto divisas cripto monedas esto
seguramente causa controversia si
santiago primero si le parece
expliquemos que son las cripto monedas
pues mire como el bitcoin por ejemplo
ellas son divisas virtuales que se
transfieren de forma electrónica en
algunos casos sirven para pagar
servicios o para invertir pero sin
embargo las autoridades de varios países
han alertado mucho sobre los riesgos en
invertir en estos esquemas que por lo
general ofrecen rentabilidades inusuales
esto debido a que hasta el momento no
son consideradas como una divisa oficial
y tampoco tienen el respaldo de los
bancos centrales lo que quiero hacer la
comisión europea de santiago es
exigirles autorizaciones previas y poner
la lupa sobre su actividad escuchemos
habrá normas especiales para las monedas
estables globales como la libra de
facebook que estarán sujetas a
requerimientos más estrictos esto por el
gran número de usuarios que podría
alcanzarse lo cual plantea un reto para
la estabilidad financiera y requiere
también más salvaguardas en términos de
fraude y lavado de dinero apenas
comienza el debate de daniela
indicadores o street de cerró con signos
positivos aunque con resultados bastante
planos podría decirse el foco ahora está
en las empresas tecnológicas bastante
volátiles en europa si hubo descensos
estuvieron guiadas por el mal dato
laboral de eeuu y los estímulos del
reino unido- y en américa latina hubo
notables ganancias en tres de los
principales índices argentina méxico y
brasil cifra del día para el cierre
buenos 165 millones de euros en
compensaciones que se comprometió a dar
vokswagen a sus ex trabajadores en
brasil eso santiago por violaciones a
los derechos humanos cometidos durante
la dictadura militar en una demanda
contra la firma ellos habían dicho que
esta oficina de seguridad de la empresa
había colaborado con el régimen militar
muchas gracias daniela por estos datos
del mundo económico
en la economía france24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]